I'm not saying that everyone in
Consulting is like that but I did find
myself for a period of time I was a
little bit like that and I felt that I
lost my humility for a while so yeah I'd
say I cannot really agree I really
cannot say that Consultants were
self-centered or arrogant or anything
like that so I met so many extremely
humble people who are working Consulting
that were just so kind so friendly so
empathetic surely as in most of these
environments there are always also
people are not so nice or not so great
people do not really enjoy hanging out
with but not to say they're consultants
in general were so arrogant and so on
that at least them in my humble
experience this is not what I saw there